the first is every restaurants worst
nightmare 30 hungry diners who arrive an
order all at the same time first they're
heading for Momo tucked away behind
London's Regent Street as run by very
passionate Lautner day he's been cooking
at the age of 15 and he now heads up a
brigade of 26 chefs this fresh has also
been visited by some serious a-listers
from Madonna to Granite Paltrow and if
they can look after those kind of
customers my diner today are in for a
real treat
hey David how are you well I think how
are you very good very good so the
success success of Momo's knew what we
all work together as a team and we
create and create an atmosphere and
hopefully delicious food yeah open 13
years ago
it's excellent food stylish surroundings
and party atmosphere quickly established
Momo as one of London's most fashionable
restaurants
soon as you enter it's like a theater
you come in you see the atmosphere you
see the deck or you see the bones you
want to get involved we got lots of film
stars lots of footballers politicians
lots of you know people want to go
through the back door
what I love most about Momo is you feel
comfortable straightaway and the
atmosphere is sexy I need one lamb
tagine or coriander three minutes yet 37
year-old David has cooked in kitchens
all over the world
cooking's been my life from from the age
of 40 and are 15 away table 50 tagine
lamb sirloin steak medium-rare yeah
during his travels in Morocco David fell
in love with North African food I love
the passion on Moroccan cuisine I think
some great flavors everybody thinks
Moroccan cuisine is couscous and tagine
its vast assisted for seven years by
French sous-chef Phillip David gives
traditional recipes his own personal
touch doesn't look like a creme brulee
that's delicious
only a Yorkshire would [ __ ] fryer
creme brulee but it works David that's
some of the best food I've tasted so far
in this competition make sure that you
give my diners the exact experience
you've just delivered to me now Momo is
about to be put through his paces
because my revenez diners have arrived
all expecting food and service fit for
London glitterati
hello welcome mmm oh and the service
shouldn't pose a problem as front of
house manager Murad has a team of nine
waiters this place deals with big
numbers easily so they can become a
little bit complacent because there's
only 30 diners Killeen and sometimes
Russians get bad reputation for just
looking after the genesis and forgetting
the real customers
so first Agana oh do one scallop one
mission weasel ooh one Fisher today two
mobiles medium as first orders arrive
head chef David directs his brigade like
a conductor with an orchestra don't
start 14 don't start six year please
don't put all nine past year at same
time please
don't know crispy that past year two
minutes past ear make sure the first
three or four tables go fast and slow
down there are three starters Moroccan
aubergine caviar with mixed peppers wood
pigeon Pass Thea a delicate North
African pie and scholars with aubergine
chutney and a fresh herb celsa David's
on fire and the first starters are out
within minutes
any problems anywhere any yeah and it
looks like we're about to get our main
course already ok well that's how the
locals don't go back as far as the
summer it would be nice to go it's the
two ladies on the end here
don't throw their main course out as
quick you know hold it back a little bit
David is doing his best to control the
flow of food sent able one slow down on
14 and six but it's front-of-house who
need to pay service and make sure every
table gets their food at the right time
I've just told the team to slow down
slow down it's not a race